well get used to this clothing for a
week so we are back with my two favorite
people and with your two favorite people
I uh and this is the one all for him the
name the unicorn is that just leaving
Rainicorn Lady Rainicorn
yes okay and who only speaks Korean yep
okay and is Jake the dog's girlfriend
and once them wants her and food to get
to know each other better because that
way he doesn't have to split up his time
being with her and being within and they
can both hang out or all three hang out
but it looks like Lady Rainicorn and
Finn the human
right that's what is the game a little
too well almost without Jake and Jake
gets really jealous and calls and
Tiffany who's a boy which I started
getting like you would make Finn jealous
and but how would it make Lady Rainicorn
jealous because they're playing viola
together oh is that so okay I get I
guess that makes sense
all right so they wouldn't be like
necessarily a love jealousy more of a
hey you're doing something with how
would a dog do it with a Rainicorn well
very carefully okay just very carefully
do you think they change colors but okay
we're really gay well actually if you
think about it Jake can actually turn
into Lady Rainicorn shape if you can
thing if you think about it I guess oh
my god like what Jake could actually do
with the fact that he can change size
and shape and we really should talk
about something not this no no this is
perfect it's going down a great road I
don't think it is I don't think it is
especially when there's so much more to
talk about in this episode like Tiffany
yes who would name the boy Tiffany yes
so now it is with Tiffany a human we
don't know okay I was gonna say cuz you
don't really see them I don't know cuz
bubblegum
might be human like the only one we've
like been told is a human is fin because
it's in the name but everything else is
drawn so strange it's like you don't
know it could be like anything so I
guess the the thing I do think of when I
see this I've seen this happen a lot of
times with couples it
I think it's happened with me too is
that when you get with someone there's
always gonna be like that person that's
like oh hey these are my friends and oh
hey this is my girlfriend or wife
whatever and it's like but they don't
like really talk the same language
that's what I almost think it was
actually very Clara she spoke Korean
whether or not that was intentional
because phen Descanso like you know
what'd she say when she's saying that
she wouldn't necessarily know what he
said um and oh god that old man boys
that's clearly not an old man it's like
obviously just someone impersonating old
man Bo oh sweet potato I mean that's
that's really funny that that killed me
Navin I come out but then when she
speaks Korean like that's hilarious -
yep because he's like I didn't I didn't
know why but she speaks adorable Korean
you just and maybe it's just because
it's coming out of that thing that you
just go oh I'm so cute everything she
talks like that
um but yeah so I think episodes like
this are kind of fun I don't know if
kids go through that as much with like
you know I guess there's gonna be like
friends that don't mesh at times and
stuff like oh that's true yes yeah but I
think there is something definitely
different like when you have someone
you're romantically into and so it's
just a friend it's like you do even if
you have like everything in common with
the person you romantically into it's
like you're still gonna talk a little
differently it's just some things that
you're gonna do differently even if
everybody gets along really well like
hey you know I'm not talking about like
the obvious our differences you know but
you know in terms of just like what you
talk about so it's I think it's kind of
cool to like it's kind of prepare kids
for that yeah it kind of says you know
you can have a friend you can have a
girlfriend and they may not you may not
be able to hang out with them all the
time but sometimes when everyone hangs
out together it just creates more
problems so it's okay to have that
separate time in that
I'm alone with them yeah although even
here I mean they they end up all hanging
out they're all stupid together of
course let's never be stupid again
no let's always be stupid ha ha ha
I just love how quickly these end - it's
like there's never any like segway out
or anything's just like stop yeah so no
I I thought was cute I thought was fun
like I said any I love to fight anytime
that thing talks it's always hilarious
cuz it's either gonna be that adorable
Korean or that old man oh yeah the basic
good episode
you know I mean you hit pretty much the
nail on the head with all of it I think
I mean did you find this nail no I'm not
looking for the dance nail okay I did
point in one episode if anyone ever
bothered to look um but but isn't there
no in like the last video long ideas
they just see the snail like I don't
know we'll put one in here somewhere
think I did somewhere in there so or did
I forget that'd be hilarious if I forgot
and everyone's going to play my frame
yeah that'd be hilarious I hope I did
that now there's a lot of few times I
really hope I forgot do you have an evil
streak yeah maybe just for maybe or
maybe I put in a frame that didn't say
like hey you found the snail or
something it's like you know it's like
go outside looking for a frame of a
snail um but yeah now I really don't
know if I put it in there no cuz I know
I did once but then there was a
nostalgia critic segue which by if you
haven't seen the continuation check out
Bennet's videos it's in there by the way
in case you missed that
I just want Barbie Long's as a segue
into another video without telling you
I'm sorry
you look hurt no I'm okay okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay so good okay okay
yes yes see you next be look